welcome back to CBS mornings now that a
new Congress has been sworn in the focus
on Capitol Hill is Shifting back to New
York Congressman George Santos the
Republican lawmaker has admitted making
up much of his resume before he was
elected to his first term in November
now a formal complaint filed with the
federal election Election Commission
accuses him of campaign Finance
violations Scott McFarland has more
beginning his third full day as a
congressman George Santos is facing a
lot of questions but he's giving no
answers Mr Santos there's some campaign
Finance concerns and questions about
your finances can you answer the
campaign Finance concerns a little
personal space
Congressman you seem to be dodging
questions about your finances Santos has
already been accused of lying about key
parts of his life story including his
education work history and claiming his
grandparents survived the Holocaust is
now the subject of a formal civil
complaint to the Federal Election
Commission a nonpartisan D.C Watchdog
group The Campaign Legal Center filed
the complaint questioning how Santos
made a 700 000 contribution to his
campaign considering he previously
reported earning about fifty thousand
dollars a year your complaints is
something pretty bold but there's a
possibility there was a foreign actor
that was funding this campaign I think
it's always a possibility when someone
appears to be going to Great Lengths to
mask the true sources of their campaigns
funds that possibility is doubly the
case here because as we know Mr Santos
is wanted by Brazilian authorities so he
has some connection overseas meanwhile
Santos is one of the needed guest votes
in the U.S house last night to approve
new rules to govern the house now under
Republican control this both the Asia
220 the Naser 213 the resolution is
agreed to another narrow margin victory
for new house Speaker Kevin McCarthy on
his first order of business as Speaker
the house will be in order
the new rules approved last night give
more members of the key committee
positions to members of the House
Freedom caucus the conservative members
of the Republican conference also makes
it easier to potentially oust speaker
McCarthy regarding that criminal
investigation in Brazil of Congressman
Santos it's tied to an alleged incident
of check fraud in 2008. Vlad
Scott I suspect that Mr Santos
Congressman Santos Has Not Seen the Last
of you or the other Capitol Hill
reporters thank you very much for your
reporting we appreciate it